they've agreed upon a 15 pay rise which
will apply to any legal aid work but the
big thing is it will be backdated that's
something that wasn't on offer uh
previously when uh then Justice
secretary Dominic Raab had proposed
these measured measures now the criminal
Bar Association say that 50 57 of its
barristers voted to end the strike
action uh they're accepting this 15 rise
and as well as that the current Justice
secretary Brandon Lewis has also offered
additional funding for other areas that
are covering other elements of Court
preparation work as well it means that
from 5 pm today the indefinite strike
action will come to an end criminal
barristers in England and Mills will be
taking on new cases and from Tomorrow
Crown courts will be resuming with cases
as normal now initially when the strike
started back in summer they were in
alternate weeks that then escalated so
from the 5th of September onwards is
when the indefinite right action began
and it's all meant that hundreds of
Trials haven't gone ahead adding to the
already existing backlog that we know
existed because exacerbated by the
pandemic but the criminal Bar
Association says that it was a largely
to do with chronic underfunding in the
criminal justice system as well
so whilst organizations are happy to see
these strikes coming to an end there's
also concerns around just how many cases
are going to be sat waiting victim
support has said that more needs to be
done to try to tackle this backlog to
reduce it they say it's a problem that's
been going on for nearly a decade now